i actually
um i actually do have a little bit of
authorization to say this that
on the way here today
i did get a phone call from trump's
lawyer from christina bob and people
have seen her all across the news lately
that you know that she's out there on
this and and look we um we both worked
together at oan in the past so i don't
think anybody you know it's a surprise
to anybody that we know each other and
yes we do still keep in contact and one
thing that she told me
while she so she was there at the
mar-a-lago raid
and she's talked about this in some
interviews already but what i asked her
as i said what did the fbi like how were
they acting
were they acting you know you know if
you got in their face they were going to
arrest you or how are they and the
weirdest thing and she said
uh that i took it was so strange that
she said
they were acting as if we could keep the
whole thing quiet if we were all just
kind of cool about it
that they actually didn't think
that trump would tell people that he had
been raided what and i said why do you
think they
they thought that and she said i think
that they thought that he
he was worried that it or he might be
worried that it would make trump look
bad and where i'm saying how did they
not understand that this makes you look
bad when you're raiding him or that this
is donald trump and then it's right the
dude
yeah and they specifically timed the
raid i understand from some of the
readings i i did that
they timed it on it
when trump would not be there because
they wanted to keep it on the down low
right and he's not usually in there
somewhere to begin with right for this
because mar-a-lago's closed for the
seasons we're on the skeleton crew right
now and when i talked to christine she
said look i i wasn't even there you know
when this whole thing started and she
you know tore down when she heard what
it was fine what's going on
got in their faces to say hey you know
what are you doing what what is all this
can you explain what's going on they
wouldn't tell her anything
um they and we've seen the search
warrant and was you know completely
perfunctory and we of course over human
events daily with the first outlet to
you know blah blah blah blah blah blah
so the doj is blocking the affidavit
right now so the doj has said now think
about this merrick garland came up two
days later and said
we will
let the information known to the
american people he said that at his
press conference and his his at the
press conference of course though his
argument was basically that hey i'm the
government you can trust me
and
then a couple days later by the way
immediately after that when he walked
off the stage that's when we got
the leak about the nukes so somebody
pops that out right after he gets off
stage about nuclear weapons which is
just immediately gone there's been a
bunch of rumors that have been flying
since then is it about ukraine is it
about you know the iran deal
whatever and
they're now fighting to keep the
affidavit under seal because they are
saying that if the affidavit becomes out
it will
injure their
investigation
and you'd think that if he were trying
to be serious about this and jonathan
turley had a piece up today
which i thought he was being a little
squishy with it but i agree with part of
it where he said look if this guy was
trying to be fair he'd at least say you
can you can release parts of it yeah
that you could release something to just
alleviate like the pressure valve just
alleviate a little bit of the pressure
let off some of the pressure
look there were some documents we were
worried about the security of it it had
some
so so derek for example one of the one
of the theories that you know myself and
other you know as a prior navy
intelligence officer one of the theories
that we had was could he have um pdbs uh
declassified copies of a pdb what's a
pdb so presidential's daily brief
presidency
a pdb now he might have it because he
wants a certain portion of it but
depending on the format it's in you
might have all sorts of cia reporting in
there
code word stuff special access pro who
knows right you could have a ton of
stuff in there
that you know would would be better
served if it were secured elsewhere
right so you know what kind of stuff
would be in the pdb
well it could be discussions about north
korean nuclear capabilities right or the
discussions or the thinking of north
korea which we only have because maybe
we have a source in kim jong-un's palace
or inside the kremlin and if you read
the report you might know
that because of the access you know the
only way someone could have this level
of information and you know oh and kim
jong-un over breakfast on wednesday said
this the problem with that is on the
pdbs is the pd books are controlled they
go in and they are returned and they're
numbered right so
but i i really think that one of the
things that they had down there were
the
uh russia hoax documents from the cia
showing cia and fbi culpability there
were numerous investigations
director radcliffe former dni director
as radcliff has talked about this
i think that's probably one of the
things that they would have had down
there because he ordered those to be
declassified the fact that doj did not
go through with
the process over there for further
dissemination of these documents as
declassified doesn't make those
documents any less so you're talking
about the underlying
spy gate documents the original
documents that started the entire
operation that became russiagate that
became the dossier everything else we're
talking about the original
um electronic communications and
everything else that was pulled during
and this when you were in uh working
with news you worked with cache patel
and so many other and
the investigation of what cia was
actually doing
and the evidence that they looked at to
come up with the conclusion that russia
wanted
trump to win in the 2016 election
there is a tremendous documentation
there that shows malfeasance and
culpability
they cherry-picked information to get to
a conclusion
and the overwhelming amount of evidence
that pointed in another direction was
put on the cutting room floor
that type of lay down is what director
radcliffe had
it's damning of the central intelligence
agency and of the fbi you know for a
fact that they had that information yes
like you did you see it
i worked on that project
and then so they would have like on a
thumb drive just copies of the emails
and stuff and all that no it was all
it was all
paper copies so but that's weird to me
that they would have like a paper copy
of it and that's it if it burns on fire
you never see it again i mean that's
very inspector gadget
um we had it in a vault in in at the cia
headquarters there are other copies so
tremendous amount of work hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours of work
by many people to go through all of the
intelligence that was available to the
central intelligence agency that they
neglected to include
and it was
information that was not consistent with
the narrative that john brennan and
and the director of national
intelligence clapper wanted to portray
to the president
in the fall of 2016 about russia wanting
trump too
i mean russia wanting trump to win was
that like trump that fire everybody
it's a good question we brought in dan
coats to be the director of national
intelligence and you wound up with
the cia director pompeo
a lot of this evidence was provided to
director pompeo in and to the deputy
director okay
haspel
and they decided to do nothing with that
information about
what cia had done to politicize their
intelligence hey derek last time i
checked maybe maybe you can refresh my
memory
who was the station chief so a lot of
this was done in london right right so
who was the cia station chief now any
human operation that's conducted
overseas must be signed off with the
purview and off really authorization of
the cia station chief for that country
that's how it works so um whoever was
run whoever was working with christopher
steele whatever fbi bruce ohr and nelly
and all this stuff in in the uk
had to be signed off by the london
station chief who was the london station
gina haspel who became the deputy
director of the cia who
also decided not to do anything right
director of cia gina so just
how all these people wind up still
popping up
you know peter strzok's wife is leading
the investigation for the securities
exchange commission about the trump
media group wow okay how does lisa
monaco wind up leading the investigation
of trump right now
deep state
it's um i mean it's not even that deep
anymore it's the in your face state yeah
they don't care they just don't care
anymore well i think they're losing and
i think they they know they're losing
and i'm not saying you know i have to
talk about this this country
destabilizing trump said something
terrible will happen unless we lower
these temperatures uh with
i think all that's true
but i think the reason the temperature
is heating up is because the
bureaucratic state the administrative
state knows they are failing they have
they have lost cohesion and they're
going to be removed very quickly donald
trump was going to fire everybody he's
planning on running and then immediately
you know the reporting is he's going to
fire everybody once again and i'd love
to see it i'm down for desantis or
anybody else but i'm kind of like maybe
the first thing we do is like you know
let's say you buy a new company you come
in you clean house you say okay this
this company's crooked it's corrupt
these employees aren't working but we
got a good base here so we're gonna fire
all these people keep the good ones very
few of them and then we're gonna start
rehiring and rebuilding this thing but
i'd love to see part of why there's
tension is because there's this lack of
vision by leadership in this country
there's no maybe not no plan but like
how often do you see someone in an
established form of government come out
and tell you about their excited plans
for the future
and get people riled up to like yes we
can change the world we can start
terraforming earth like but where's the
real change
proposals from donald i didn't see
pretty much like where is he talking
about fusion for the love of god fusion
power or space trap that's just
something he's talking about space
travel quite a bit a little bit not only
he started space force he started space
wars and he wants to go to mars
he wants a base on the moon to bring us
to mars talking could have done more on
nuclear sure yeah he could have done
more but okay so maybe some people are
or you can say something well i was
going to say that you know president
trump
looked for new ideas and he wanted to
execute a reinvention of the pentagon
taking a good look at how we do health
care in this country but
when you have 4 000 political appointees
and you don't get most of your people
through the senate or into the
the lower positions and the ones that
you are getting are people like director
ray the establishment provided him as
this guy's vetted he's good he's
reliable and look what we get when we
get director ray he's part of the rhino
class
there you go when donald when they were
talking about climate change and then i
think donald trump was like i'd never
heard him be like let's fix it it was
more like
uh that's not as big of a problem as
you're making it out to be kind of meant
i don't want to be too hard on don
because he had a big job um but i think
we can fix the climate so like i don't
know man i don't know that's what we
need i think we will de-escalate
tensions when we start producing a myth
a modern myth that we can get behind
just a modern story put a pin on this
that
the people that get me though are the
ones who say oh well trump couldn't
destroy the or you know defeat the
entire establishment in one term i guess
that means he sucks now we should just
stop trying i mean
really if you actually think you're up
against these all-powerful masters of
the universe who have so much ability
they stole his presidency right control
all of this they took away his what
first three two and a half years just
two minutes three years two and a half
years and then you get caught into covet
in the last year and then impeached him
and then coveted and even even with all
that we had gas prices were dropping the
economy was booming imagine what he
could have actually accomplished if he
wasn't jammed up with with russiagate
right and that's not cope that's just
that's just what happened okay that's
what happened and if you can't be adult
enough to sit there and look at the
situation
objectively and say yes this was run
against him because trump winning the
white house was a beachhead okay that
was a head that you established but
you're still surrounded in washington dc
by the administrative state and they
came for him they came into the white
house
i remember there was a viral tweet from
one of these lawyers that said we are
going to impeach you
the day like he was getting enough yes
right right from the very beginning so
for my own
my own my own experience
i went in and took over the middle east
effort in the national security council
for the president they went after mike
flynn and took mike flynn out
and mike flynn wanted to execute and
move on the president's agenda for the
middle east he wanted
a new approach for the middle east peace
talks he wanted to move the embassy from
tel aviv to jerusalem he wanted his
first trip overseas to be to saudi
arabia and israel he wanted to get out
of the iran deal
mattis and tillerson
and mcmaster opposed him on all those
initiatives
deep state derek is it true that
mcmaster would
would essentially just just go into him
and and fudge the numbers on syria
withdrawals and everything like that
there was a
in meetings that i participated in there
was a mischaracterization
provided to the president by tillerson
mattis
and mcmaster
i was sitting on this on the the love
seat
behind the view of the the president
could see me and those three were
sitting right in front of the oval
in the oval office in front of president
trump's desk
and i was right in the line of sight of
of the president and they were telling
him things and i was shaking my head no
and the president would say
my guys are telling me there's another
way of looking at this my guys are
telling me that there's new information
on this
he would challenge general mattis
they couldn't see me shaking my head
but he picked up on those signals
correctly wow but they were providing
him wrong numbers
mischaracterizing what was actually
going on
and trying to just
[ __ ] him
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there